hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
the company meta has been in the news
for multiple reasons Lately from staff
hijacking user accounts and allegedly
taking bribes to a falling stock price
Mass layoffs increasingly ineffective
business model and of course a failing
metaverse project their most recent
financial report showed a 52 decrease in
net profit for the quarter
it seems like the company that everyone
loves to hate is in serious trouble if
nothing changes in this episode we will
discuss the flailing of the once
Unstoppable Giant
[Music]
meta investors are not happy at all
they've seen flat growth decreased
revenue and profit less than a year ago
meta was valued at nearly a trillion
dollars today it's worth less than a
third of that to put it another way the
fall has been so dramatic that its stock
price is back to January of 2016 levels
if you invested in meta at that time
without pulling profits you've lost
money this year meta is down 70 percent
making it the worst performing stock in
the entire s p 500.
[Music]
to begin to understand the full picture
of why meta is collapsing we have to go
back to 2005 at this time Facebook then
president Sean Parker would help Mark
Zuckerberg navigate his way around
Silicon Valley but he would also help
Mark gain complete control of the
company
under the guidance of Sean Zuckerberg
would set up the company so he was
essentially King
he overruled everyone even the board of
directors he couldn't be touched and it
would stay this way indefinitely
this dictatorship would come back to
hurt the company
in the 2010s users started to move from
desktops to smartphones although
Facebook adapted Mark Zuckerberg still
felt like there could have been more of
a player in the hardware space Facebook
tried releasing their own smartphone in
2013 but the public thumbed their nose
at it Mark needed to try something else
and in 2014 he would find it
when Zuckerberg saw an Oculus demo he
was sold he was convinced that VR would
be the future of computing he would then
buy Oculus for 2 billion and went all in
even changing the company's name and
spending 10 billion dollars a year on
Research to make his vision a reality
and herein lies one of the major issues
because Mark was King nobody within the
company could stop him even if they
thought it was a bad idea
though in my opinion technology overall
seems to be going in a direction where a
widely used metaverse environment for
the masses will become inevitable a
virtual space where an online life is
lived in VR but there's a problem is
this future five years away or 15 years
away if it's five years away meta might
be able to hang on and ride it out but
if it's 15 years away this is a major
issue and shareholders aren't going to
tolerate it for investors it feels like
Zuckerberg is hinging his Titan company
on something that the world just isn't
ready for yet
Apple successfully broke through this
issue with the iPhone meta isn't on the
same level here or at least just yet
on the hardware side they're doing some
cool things and have sold over 10
million VR headsets which is good but on
the software side meta's Flagship
metaverse product Horizon worlds looks
horrendous
really I can't believe that over 15
billion dollars went into the creation
of this
the metaverse is now loaded create your
avatar you might be wondering hey what's
going on with the resolution uh let me
show you what it's like if I uncrop it
okay
bear in mind I've done this before on
capture for other games on Oculus right
that's not happened I've never had it
like kind of happen to that degree so
not a good start and that's why I've had
to crop it because I don't want to give
make people sick Avatar legs may not be
available in all app experiences well I
thought that was the [ __ ] point of
the last conference
just trying to navigate them I'm just
trying to navigate the menu oh dear God
this only has 197 likes reason I'm
drawing attention to this is this is
probably the same first world it shows
to everyone and like only 200 people
gave it a thumbs up go to the arcade
okay the arcade I will I will check out
the arcade
um thank you so much guys see yeah later
dude right everyone's still in my ears
can you hear me is he gone he's dead
all right he died
why can't I hear him no guys I'm here
I'm here okay I'm trying to get in the
menu everybody
[Music]
I'm it crashed
15 billion dollars well spent I think
Zuckerberg isn't actually wrong that VR
will be the technology that connects
people in a way the other technology
simply can't
but there's just so much work that needs
to be done
it's Palmer lucky the founder of oculus
puts it Horizon worlds is a poor product
that isn't Fun quote it's terrible today
but it could be amazing in the future
and the thing is it's not like creating
a great VR experience is impossible VR
chat is already Miles Ahead in many
aspects
in August of 2022 the vice president of
horizon worlds left it's not spelling
the most confidence of behind the scenes
activity
the second issue is the crippling of the
main source of revenue for meta targeted
advertising and once again to fully
understand this we have to go back this
time to 2008
in this year Facebook would hire Google
ad executive Cheryl stanberg as Chief
Operating Officer
in those early days she would balance
Mark's Reckless Behavior but moreover
she was instrumental in creating what
would Propel Facebook into the
stratosphere extremely effective
Advertising based on the personal data
of users it worked so well that very
early employees became Rich this was
great for wallets but bad for consumers
users absolutely hated it when they
found out that they were being exploited
but it didn't matter because the company
was making money hand over fist though
without knowing it meta had now become
vulnerable to any outside entity that
choked off its data collecting and this
is exactly what happened in 2021
Tim Cook would mandate that iPhone users
could switch off their ad targeting and
meta lost billions we've done a full
episode on this which I'll link below
statistically iPhone users tend to spend
more money than Android ones so this
move by Apple severely Hurt Facebook
according to David Wenger meta's Chief
Financial Officer advertisers are now
starting to move to Google
with meta's vaporized profits all was
now laid bare and open to clear scrutiny
frankly meta is a company that isn't
improving their core products
improvements to user interface and user
experiences are left on the back burner
instead meta focuses on stealing other
features from other platforms such as
reels from Tick Tock and implementing
them into Instagram but competing with
one of the best social media algorithms
on Earth is a tall task reels aren't as
effective at making money as Instagram's
other features as for the user
experience Instagram is now choked with
ads and are straying ever further away
from its original idea
for its first decade back when it was
Facebook The Firm used to innovate on
the social media front this stage is
clearly over
in early 2022 long-time CEO Cheryl
Sandberg who was supposedly the adult in
the room left meta now Mark Zuckerberg
is a king without any guard rails
most recently Facebook has laid off 11
000 staff or 13 of their Workforce even
though higher interest rates are
demolishing high-risk Investments such
as big Tech any stock Falling by 70
percent in a year is nothing to sneeze
at
Zuckerberg states that over investment
was the issue he doesn't seem to see
doubling down on the metaverse as an
issue to investors
on the 10th of November in a call with
investors he would state that he thought
the surge of e-commerce from covert
would be permanent so he significantly
increased his Investments and quote
unfortunately this did not play out the
way I expected not only has online
Commerce returned to Prior Trends but
the macro economic downturn increased
competition and add signal loss have
caused our Revenue to be much lower than
I'd expected I got this wrong and I take
responsibility for that
Beyond Financial woes meta is facing
investigations from the FTC and a whole
host of lawmakers anti-trusters looming
and threatening either to break up the
company or make it harder for them to
Simply acquire companies like they could
in the past
I also don't have to reiterate all the
scandals like Cambridge analytica leaked
documents on Mental Health and Social
division the demographic shift also
wasn't helping tiktok has eaten meta's
lunch both on Facebook and Instagram
according to Kevin Rose of the New York
Times despite older people generally
having more funds advertisers love to
follow the younger demographic
long story short meta is in an identity
crisis with a king who has tunnel vision
so what can be done well looking at it
from the outside there should be some
soul searching meta is already two
companies so perhaps Mark should embrace
this
one company is a pure technology company
aiming to create the metaverse the other
is a social media and advertising
business and this company has lost the
attention of its CEO maybe it's time for
the social media part to be a proper
subsidiary run by another CEO
the only bright Ray of Hope is that meta
still has almost 4 billion customers
there's a lot of potential to turn it
around but one will they and two do we
even really want that let's just say if
we had a metaverse for the masses built
by someone else I wouldn't be sad
so what do you guys think feel free to
discuss in the comment section below
anyway that's about it from me my name
is Togo and you've been watching cold
fusion feel free to take a browse to the
channel and see if you like anything
else on here and I'll catch you again
soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking